nous allons arriver au sommet quel que
soient les difficultés parce que les
Français veulent le renouvellement de la
vie politique faire pr de renouveau Ren
le maire veut garder le cap et répète
son message à l'envie depuis des
semaines un slogan et une marque de
fabrique également scandé hier par
l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture en
meting à Saint-Germain l et qui semble
ravir ses futurs électeurs à la primaire
ah ben c'est déjà ce qui me pousse aller
vers Bruno Le Maire puisque j'exclu
voter pour quelqu'un qui a pas un casé
judiciaire vierge j'exclu de voter pour
les sortants puisquils un bilan le fait
de porter une certaine éthique pour moi
c'est très
important un certain dynamisme une
jeunesse et l'envie de nouveau éducation
sécurité ou encore économie le candidat
à la primaire a développé une partie de
son programme devant plusieurs dizaines
de ses partisans lui qui reste optimiste
malgré des sondages qui le placent loin
derrière encore les ténors du parti
beaucoup de gens me disent voilà on
voterait bien pour vous mais on veut
avoir l'assurance que Nicolas Sarkozi
soit battu donc on va voter pour Alain
Jupé je trouve que c'est pas une bonne
motivation pour son vote on doit voter
pour un projet et pour une personne qui
porte ce projet pas contre un homme ou
contre une personne ce deuxième
déplacement dans les ivelines en
l'espace de quelques mois a permis
également au députés de l'heure de
mesurer ses soutiens dans le département
on a aujourd'hui environ 1200 militants
sur le département ce qui fait une force
de mobilisation importante et on a
aujourd'hui à peu près 120 130 élus
locaux qui nous ont rejoint un certain
nombre de maires Laurent Bros benasa
Bernard grouko plusieurs conseillers
départementaux et régionaux et donc on a
une vraie force politique et populaire
qui permet de de porter notre candidat
prochain grand oral pour Bruno Le Maire
jeudi 3 novembre date du 2e débat de la
primaire rressement